[Music]
the two main characters of ursula k le
guin's second earth sea novel the tombs
of ottawa are arya or tenar who runs
through the entirety of the work and ged
the main character of the previous novel
a wizard of earth see he's now a wizard
of earth
and he appears about a little bit before
midway
through the novel and at first their
relationship is one that's
antagonistic
much more on ara's side than it is on
ged's side who's trying to get in there
find the missing half of the ring of
ereth ekba that he's looking for
and then get out of there whereas arya
is living there she is the girl who
began as tenar
becomes the devoured one she is the high
priestess of the nameless ones the
powers of the earth below the tombs that
dominate the entire area and at one
point in time were very important for
the kargish lands
now there's a
passage that happens before she
encounters ged where this is partly her
coming of age coming into power and she
has to decide
what to do
the determination
of how to
kill how to sacrifice how to bring about
the death of these prisoners that have
been sent to her
as
oblations you could say for the nameless
ones who she serves and there's a lot of
discussion back and forth between her
and
castle about exactly what kind of death
is is appropriate and they're
essentially left to
die of starvation and thirst so
she's already wrapped her head around
this notion
of
being in charge
of the under tombs and being in charge
of the life and death of people as a
matter of fact after that incident after
she gets over
her
negative affects about that that are
coming out in dreams she starts planning
what she might do to future
sacrifices and then something happens
she runs into somebody
ged a wizard
one of those people from the
inner lands
one of those
accursed sorcerers
and she
sees him
crawling around
in the vast chamber of the undertomb she
actually yells go go be gone to to him
and
why does she do that well because of the
light that is profaning
the sacred space of the undertomb here
we go she saw
what she had never seen not though she
lived a hundred lives the great vaulted
cavern below the tombstones not hollowed
by man's hand but by the powers of the
earth and it's a beautiful sight which
we'll talk about elsewhere
but she sees this as a sacrilege that is
being committed sacrilege the word came
slowly into araha's mind this is a man
and no man's foot must ever touch the
soil of the tombs the holy place yet he
had come down so this is
angering her and it's also angering the
great powers of the earth the nameless
ones of oto on
what she ends up doing
is
going down there
and she traps him
he knows that he's being
pursued the light goes out
right his wizard staff
and she in effect is
stalking him
right
he was not in the tunnel she was sure of
it so close in that cramped place she
would have heard his breath felt the
warmth and pulse of his life itself
where had he gone
she went slowly forward now unsure
her ears told her no more than her eyes
but as she stood with one hand on either
side of the rock she felt a faint
obscure vibration in the rock and on the
chill stale air was the trace of the
scent that did not belong there the
smell of the wild sage that grew on the
desert hills slow and quiet she moved
down the corridor following her nose
after perhaps a hundred paces she heard
him he was almost as silent as she but
she was not so he was not so sure footed
in the dark she heard a light slight
scuffle as if he'd stumbled on the
uneven floor and recovered himself at
once
and then there's this you know moving
around a little bit and then finally
a rounded bar of metal she waited until
this happens a rounded bar of metal came
under her fingertips she stopped felt up
the strip of iron until almost as high
as she could reach she touched a
projecting handle of rough iron this
suddenly with all her strength she
dragged downward there was a fearful
grinding and a clash blue sparks left
out in a falling shower echoes died away
she put out her hands and felt only a
few inches before her face the pocked
surface of an iron door what has
happened now
she has trapped him in the labyrinth
this vast maze
of corridors and rooms
underneath the tombs of antoine where
the treasures
are as well as some other
very interesting things as well
and so long as that door is shut
he cannot get out
he's now trapped
and so she goes to tell castle there's a
question well what should we do with him
obviously he has to die but how will he
die and how long will it take before he
dies
she expresses arha
that she wants to keep him alive
at least for a while to make him suffer
to taunt him and this is a way in which
arja who doesn't really have power over
her own life
now is able to have power over another
person's life and so she spies on him
through the many different peepholes
that are available
at places that she knows and also castle
knows
and
the the other high priestess does as
well because they're the ones who taught
it to her
and she talks to him at first her
talking to him is essentially taunting
him
and then it's giving him
directions directions that she doesn't
think he'll really be able to
use that well and she considers perhaps
she should give him water why
because that will keep him alive
longer it'll
permit her to keep exerting this power
over him the power of essentially being
a
slave right
so
later on
she and my nan go
into the hall down into the under tomb
they open the iron door of the labyrinth
right and this is when the
light has gone out and perhaps he might
just be
waiting in in you know to to attack them
or he might have died or something in
between
she says they lit the lanterns at the
iron door of the labyrinth arha led the
way to the painted room and from it
started on the way to the great treasury
the thief had not got very far she and
manan had not walked 500 paces on their
torturous course when they came upon him
crumpled up in the narrow corridor like
a heap of rags thrown down he had
dropped his staff before he fell it lay
some distance from him his mouth was
bloody his eyes half shut
menon says well he's still alive should
i strangle him and she says no i want
him alive pick him up and bring him
after me and madan says well why what's
going on here and here's where the line
comes in
to be a slave of the tombs be still with
your talk and do as i say a little bit
later
manon is going to say to him say to her
i i don't understand i don't question
but what good is he as a slave to the
nameless ones he is a man little one and
she says you're a fool but on i am the
one who gets to decide what to do with
him
he's going to be a slave to the tombs
what does that mean is he a slave to the
nameless ones no
he's really more a slave to arja
at this point in time
she holds his life in her hands quite
literally she can extend it she can end
it
and what does she do she brings him food
and water as a matter of fact she starts
to starve herself fasting so that she
can bring him the food that she's
supposed to be eating and something is
developing between them at first he's
entirely in her power entirely her
subject entirely her slave to do with
whatever she wants to we very often
forget that one
key part of slavery is not just that you
have to do what somebody else says
but that somebody else holds power of
life and death over you
and that is what she is enjoying at this
point in time
she converses with him at first the
conversations are rather
antagonistic she
um tells him that you know
once they they exchange name she says
you came to
worship the the uh uh the nameless ones
i came to rob him she stared at his
grave face braggart right and she uh
says what are you a god a king she's so
she's mocking him and he returns
courtesy to her he says my lady i do not
mean offense i'm a stranger and a
trespasser i do not know your ways nor
the courtesies do the priestess of the
tombs i am at your mercy and i ask your
pardon if i offend you and that's when
she gives them the jug of water and says
drink
if you like and she begins to ask him
questions questions about his scars
whether he's a dragon lord questions
about what he's seeking questions about
what he's seen outside of that domain
and
in the end there's something that's
going to be provoked by this kossil
the high priestess of the god king
is looking in through one of these
peepholes while she's carrying on
this conversation
right and
she ends up having to
do something in order to to save him
save him at least for
the moment but before that she demands
of him that he
show her some magic
right she says
[Music]
here we go so long as you have some art
to show me you'll stay alive if you have
none if it's all foolery and lies then
why then i'll have done with you do you
understand
and he says listen i can do some magic
but
i'm holding back the powers of the earth
right now and i don't have my staff and
any sort of illusion that i would do you
would see through right away so
why
should i do that your you know
my purpose and desire is to stay alive
and she said oh you'll stay alive a
while can't you see that you are stupid
all right show me these illusions i know
them may be false and won't be afraid of
them i wouldn't be afraid if they were
real as a matter of fact but you go
ahead your precious skin is safe for
tonight at least and he does show her a
few things but then
castle is listening in and she says your
magic is mere folly for the eyes of
children it is trickery and lies i've
seen enough you will be fed to the
nameless ones i will not come again
and she has manon take him
to
another place he's taken to the great
treasure room
now this is very interesting because
this hides him from castle they actually
dig a fake grave for him
but
it's also where he gets to
find what he's looking for she says this
is the place you sought this is the
great treasure of the tombs you have
come to it you cannot ever leave it
you said you wanted to stay alive this
is the only place i know where you can
stay alive
castle will kill you or make me kill you
sparrowhawk but here she cannot reach
and she gives him a little bit of
consolation you could have never left
the tombs in any case don't you see this
is no different
at least you've come to the end of your
journey what you sought
is here and she
has the chain
removed from him and now he gets to
go through the treasures that are under
there but he's in the depth of the
labyrinth
where he has no hope for escape on his
own is he still a slave
yes and no and as we're going to see
now as the novel proceeds
there's something new that's going to
develop between them it's no longer this
despotic
mistress to slave
relation that she imposed on him
at the start
you